I can only answer this question for the
role that art has had in my life and why
I wanted to do this book I think when
you see something that you relate to a
story that you relate to it makes you
feel less lonely in this world I think
art has the ability to mobilize and
inspire and make people aspire so I mean
that's that's the great place of art I
think art makes us better and I think
there was for me a real gap in the issue
of human rights and the lack of I don't
know accessible art I guess that could
sort of make people understand and
relate to these these stories in ways in
which they would perhaps do something
and to stop it is it funded enough no no
it's it's really been very difficult and
it should be funded for so many reasons
because without art it's a flat society
we need that we need that inspiration
and without art our world is a dead
place so you know and the role of
amateur art are out sometimes I think of
it as outsider art that has a tremendous
place it really says a lot about the
culture somebody comes from and there's
something really raw and pure about
having somebody who's not trained just
right and just photograph there's it's
almost like a smudge that's so fresh you
can touch it and that's that's that's
time well that's why I believe in this
so much